listen I do want to give you flowers off
top because critics are already saying
that this movie is Rock Solid they're
saying that it breeds new life into this
franchise you're not even fully out of
the gate yet but you're already getting
this kind of love how does that make you
feel it feels good it feels like you
know people are getting the work you
know that they understand what we were
trying to say what we were doing
um and and that that it feels good to be
understood a little bit you know
especially you know it doesn't always
happen this way and um and I know in the
third installment I understand the
expectations of you know like low you
know but what for what it was but but we
use that as fuel you know and um and we
just try to be truthful and tell the
best story we could the one and only
Adonis Creed you're the best pound
fighter in the world three years ago
it's been a minute since you've been out
in these streets when I walked away from
boxing I walked away with some
unfinished business it just left me in
like a puddle I'm like what is he trying
to do today I just need to see boxing
what is he trying to do to my heart here
but you know Channing Tatum told me once
he would never direct an act again you
did pull double duty what do you think
about that I I'll do it again I'll do it
again I'll do it again I think you know
I was so comfortable with the the story
the character in the world because you
know being there from day one of Creed
one you know and all the way through
through Creed Three
um I had a handle on the character you
know it was the only guy that I played
three times before and over the course
of like you know eight or nine years so
that was a big chunk of like my career
and like the changes and the growth that
I was going through and the growing
pains and I could kind of imagine what
Adonis Creed was going through during
his growing pain moments as well don't
let him draw everything you've found
you've found everything we've built
so to be able to kind of blur those
lines and maybe work out some of my you
know I'm saying at the same time so you
know it was uh you know that's what
acting and storytelling is about
sometimes especially as an actor you
want to kind of work something out in
your characters as you go through it and
now that you say that I could see that
you got you got grown a
kidding the dress the way you walk the
way you carried yourself it was grown
seriously so you did I like that you
said you worked some of your real life
stuff out in what we saw in this film
how did Ryan guide you with this well
you guys have been like each other's
Muse for a while and he kind of sparked
your interest in directing right
definitely yeah so that I mean that
interest got sparked back in Frugal
station just when I first kind of just
saw you know that guy up close and
personal looked like me directing
commanding a set was like wow okay and
he's like yeah you could do it too and
that's kind of where the idea kind of
started
um and as we you know finding the right
thing and the right time you know
honestly for him he was you know he was
in the middle of black panther you know
and and handling you know everything
that he had to handle around that
project and all the obstacles so to be
able to you know if I needed a you know
9-1-1 phone call hey man Big Brother
about X Y and Z about this about that he
was always kind of you know available
for that but um yeah man he uh he I also
know he wants to create distance from
this as well you know and and let me do
my thing so that's always uh you know
that you know and that's who he is
Prosper didn't have your life in the
cell watching somebody else live your
life
I'm coming for it all last time I talked
to Jonathan for Ant-Man I told him he is
now becoming the internet's boyfriend
hey well as long as we have a great
relationship as long as we stay we stay
committed to each other you know and
when we part ways we part ways amicably
we just will remember me so were y'all
having like okay let's see who can get
finer
for the internet for this film no I just
think he got two guys that work you know
OD all the time you know on whatever you
know we put our minds to you know and
and we're competitive with each other
but but it's all love you know like I I
told him you know look so when you come
to this movie you know I'm shooting this
like a show you know what I'm saying
yeah like like I want I want I want to
really like you know show the world what
I know you know and I'm glad that
everybody's getting caught up on
everything Jonathan Mages right now
that's that he's the guy and I I love
and support that you know what was your
body fat I don't even uh you know where
I stopped counting oh stop oh you know
what I stopped I promise I didn't know I
don't know what it was on this one I
don't I know I mean this is probably
like we needed to make creep for like an
underdog okay you know what I'm saying
like we need a new I wanted you guys
going into that last fight not knowing
what who was going to win you know so so
so you know we had we needed somebody
you know physically you know performable
and you know on top of your stuff you
know well you're the king of the clinch
jaw he's the king of the purse lips
it's a battle
[Music]